but the taliban have already stripped
women and girls in afghanistan of many
of their human rights and big question
marks still hang over their future as
the militants have so far failed to
elaborate on what they have in store for
women dw's terry schultz met one afghan
journalist in brussels who is trying to
help the women still in afghanistan
determined to fight for their rights
the taliban tried to brutally crush
dissent in afghanistan
women pushed to go back into burqas
beaten for daring to demand their rights
warned to stay home activists are
mobilizing in private like those who
join lailuma sadid virtually at her
dinner table thousands of miles away in
belgium
sadid the only afghan journalist in
brussels and herself once a political
refugee has become the voice of her
endangered friends
the day after kabul fell sadid made
international headlines with a
heart-wrenching appeal to nato secretary
general jen stoltenberg there is
thousands of women are really don't know
for the future what is going on and what
should happen for them and they are
always asking
what does it mean 20 years and i would
like
to ask as a woman please please don't
recognize the taliban and don't put us
against the same situation
sadid makes no apologies for the fact
her long career in journalism which
brought death threats from the taliban
decades ago has now become activism if
not her she says then who
here i have access with the european
union with the nato and also maybe with
a lot of international community if i
stay quite then the girls in afghanistan
will not forgive me
they say that we
doesn't have the choice like like you
the choices women activists face are
stark we're disguising their identities
for their safety as they plan out a
nationwide demonstration for later this
month they know the consequences could
be deadly
i'm ready to
to be killed by them but i want to
move on
yeah yeah fight yes
okay great yes
and that's my right if i tell my death
that way and i don't think that it will
be bad for me even being so far away
though sadid can't completely escape the
risks
your own mother has said please stop
you're putting us in danger
this is a terrible choice for you to
have to make
i know it's not easy
to accept but
there is no choice
what should we do if we stay quiet then
we stay quiet and silent forever
and she says then she would not be able
to forgive herself